how you doing
what's the word man you work here
[Applause]
you're getting weapons on you right now
you got any weapons on you or anything
like that
you have a weapon on you yeah what do
you have uh
380 back real quick I'm gonna attend you
for a second okay can you put your
cigarette out
[Applause]
you can drop all that I don't want to
break it up do you have a
concealed carry permit
I hear what you're saying man where's
your 380 at
okay just hang tight for me okay
is it right here yeah
is it your registered firearm yeah
registered okay
I got my apartment
you got anything else oh that's it but
nothing's gonna stick or poke me no nice
don't need nothing like that okay
I'm 10-2 I got a firearm secured
you got an idea on your partner oh yeah
there are firearms registered you
correct yes
okay I'm going to come here man smoke a
cigarette where do you live at
I'll pick the path
okay
when you reach it into your your pocket
like that when I'm coming up on you and
you got a firearm in your pocket that's
a
they don't have a permit for it's kind
of a
bad situation okay oh we're not
beautiful yeah no right now I will I
will advise you that you're going to be
you're under arrest right now because
you're
you're carrying a concealed weapon
that's not permitted so your detainment
did turn into a rest just now but we're
going to talk about that in a second
okay we're gonna work on some further
information for you yeah we'll see
what's going on I'm gonna take out my
cigarettes I just left 3D you just left
QD yeah I'm gonna show you my cigarettes
that's why I want my pocket okay you got
any warrants out for your rest right now
uh have you ever been on supervision
before what's that like
uh probation no
[Applause]
no can I have your walk over here
well if you can secure this firearm for
me it's in my right hand
[Applause]
get my uh record around real quick
have a seat back here partner what's
your first name Anthony we're gonna have
a conversation a second okay buddy yeah
hang tight
can you hit that back light for him so
he's lit up
[Applause]
here we go good yeah
I came over here I realized that I was
looking at this business looking no one
opened some lawyering back here made
contact with them asked him if he had
any firearms on him he's paused and
stared at me so do you have a gun on you
or do you have a weapon on you yeah 37
my pocket so I linked them up real quick
grab the weapons you got CCW for this no
I'm working on it so we're gonna wanna
find out who he is and uh go from there
you got my keys
[Applause]
yeah
can you do me a favor
actually check that
yeah it is
CEO number
Co numbers right here if you wouldn't
mind running that too
[Applause]
let's figure this out real quick okay
yeah
but first I gotta
I gotta read your Miranda Rights okay
you got the right treatment thing you
said can't wait to be old you can shoot
on a court of law you gotta write your
own attorney you have him or her present
here when I'm questioning before
questioning okay if you can't afford an
attorney won't be appointed to you at no
expense of you okay uh understanding
your rights right here you want to speak
with me about what's going on
yeah normally I go to QD I just brought
a pack of cigarettes I normally come
here you know just to get out the house
a little bit yeah
yeah without reach into my pocket I was
gonna show you my cigarettes okay
okay which was in the top pocket
it's a big old dog oh and I like what
type of friend make the character 380.
you know you don't got a permit for it
no but I'm working on it I was working
on getting my uh did you know that you
needed the permit to carry that 380
yeah man yeah but it's late I'm going to
the store yeah and um why are you
carrying it
protection protection protection
but like I said I just left QD I
normally come here smoke a cigarette are
you working on getting your permit yeah
okay but you know you're not supposed to
share I got my certificate for the um
that Virginia uh
the is that is that firearm registered
to you yeah where'd you buy it at
[Music]
how long ago did you buy it I brought
that uh
in the March and the March how much you
buy it for
two two fourteen two fourteen yeah
it's your first time
yeah yeah
Anthony what's your middle name Anthony
hey
like that
NCR
date of birth
for you Anthony
I'm sorry I got my fourth season it's
okay man I appreciate you
to your address
so tonight what time did you go up to QD
uh I always go about one third around 1
30. I just left the little lady here
Tony
I'm on camera you can check the cameras
get a pack of cigarettes come here smoke
turn my head
bring my little gun with me I know I'm
supposed to
it's registered in my name
and you know you're not supposed to
carry that a permit but you're caring to
protect yourself yeah
yeah like like times like this
[Applause]
when you left the house where did you
get the firearm from in your house where
do you keep it in my room in a room so
what pocket did you put in when you left
your house
you put it in your front left pocket
yeah
my cigarettes on my top pocket that's
why
I want to go show you the pack of
cigarettes you do you know anything
about this building here but you just
come here often to smoke cigarettes yeah
and if they got cameras over there
how long ago did you start working on
your uh your uh thing for your permit
or March and
is that when you pick the firearm up
yeah
where'd you buy it from
the pop shop where the Capital Discount
how much do you buy it for
214 219.
all right boss hang tight for me okay
yeah
a Ruger 380.
foreign
[Applause]
so
I was out here just checking out the nip
and sip uh
like troll the area make sure that
that's taken care of came out here
observed receptive over here uh observed
observe this subject over here uh
and I looked at the total health
education sign trying to see whether or
not this building was viable an area
that someone should
have checked it see what is going on
here if he's loitering freaking entering
do we think that check him out so make
contact with him today sir you know you
make contact and asked me if you had uh
any any weapons on him at which time he
started reaching his coat
if stop real quick you know like hey you
got any weapons on you and I said yeah I
do so turn around put his hands behind
his back he advised it he hit a 380 in
his pocket
put them in handcuffs prior to searching
for that three or for grabbing that 380
to secure that weapon from him he
advised during that time that he did not
have a CCW so all right uh we're gonna
seize this weapon and he's gonna be
picked on uh CCW down yeah
[Applause]
yep I'll pull that just a second yeah
I've never done that before so
I appreciate it
link numbers
because the cat's down otherwise I just
put them
we'll uh address that and go take it
from there no I mean this is
response
yep I know like I said we have been
having breaking and entering some of
that nip and Sip and
check the security of that and observe
them over here on the bike and
you've won the two
[Applause]
foreign
I'll give you a shout and uh
[Applause]
one more bag
foreign
hey John I'm gonna do one more search
just uh
we're good to go try to go to jail
real quick
let's face the the emblem right here on
the car one more time Partners here
gonna light you up so we have a good uh
idea what's going on I'm gonna search
you one more time prior to take it down
so like I said you are under arrest for
that CCW what's gonna happen is this
why you're carrying that
[Applause]
the actual permit to carry that firearm
however city of Lansing State of
Michigan when you do have a firearm like
that concealed and your person is indeed
a crime okay and as our job as Law
Enforcement Officers to affect arrests
on that so that's why I want to ask you
what's that it's a felon yes sir have
you been charged with a crime before
so uh I was telling you before uh
we'll go through the court proceeding
proceeding your side of the story so
it'll be in the report when that goes
over to our prosecuting attorney so they
have an idea of exactly what's going on
with you okay yeah uh I'll make sure I
can take care of that for you and again
nothing else on you gotta worry about
anything sticker poke me no drugs no
cardics or bombs knives anything like
that
next I like to do a thorough check prior
to taking anyone up to the jail if you
have any uh Contraband on you when you
get up there it's a it's actually
another felony show
s you had drugs or anything up there
Contraband Style on you uh
with the jail uh they would consider
that
saves people a lot of grief when we
figure it out out here and then uh we
can all be honest and take care of our
business you know what I'm saying yeah
[Applause]
go let's break your legs out partner
nothing inside those shoes we gotta
worry about it like that okay I'm gonna
grab this license out the floor and then
grab the rest of your property let's put
my seat and we'll have you have a seat
one more time okay
so I can go to prison for this they're
gonna talk to the prosecuting attorney
about it is what's gonna happen
okay or it's not up to us it's up to the
circumstances around the situation okay
[Applause]
and you have no criminal history